oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here all right right
off the top shout out to the new water
bottles that are finally in the
mkbhd.com store
solid metal double insulated 18 ounces
and we did make a light mode and a dark
mode
and normally i am a dark mode type of
person but i think this might be the
first time i'm actually a little more
drawn to and have been using light mode
just saying i'll leave that up to you
guys to choose i'll keep an eye on which
one sells more but choose wisely
either way they hydrated but either way
this
this right here is the valve steam deck
teased it a little while ago it turns
out there's a lot of hype around this
and now that i've been using it for a
bit i can clearly see that there's not a
lot of people that i would actually
recommend this to but
for those people
they're going to have a lot of fun with
it so the steam deck is a 399 dollar
handheld gaming console with a screen
surrounded by non-removable controls
with basically a mini pc inside if you
haven't heard about it it can kind of be
difficult to understand what a steam
deck is i guess the natural reaction is
oh it's a like a nintendo switch on
steroids but it really is a lot more
than that now valve isn't exactly known
for making a ton of great hardware like
we know steam of course and they make
some games but they have made some less
successful hardware projects like they
made the steam controller which was
eventually discontinued and the steam
link which was also discontinued and
let's not even get started on steam
machines and it's not even clear at this
point how long the steam deck will last
but i'm rooting for it so the challenge
for the steam deck is this is meant to
be able to play any of the games in your
steam library
wherever you want which is an amazing
goal but
the problem is a lot of these games all
are designed with different controller
mechanics in mind some of them are for
mouse and keyboard some of them are for
a controller some of them are just a
keyboard some of them are hybrids
whatever you want and so the steam deck
is trying to let you play as many of
those games as possible
by adapting to them now i don't know
what kind of gamer you are but for me
personally i get like really heavy into
one maybe two games at a time and then i
play them a ton until i'm sick of them
and then i move on you know some other
people have a bunch of games and
rotation
for either person though basically i
don't think you're going to be able to
be quite as good at the game as you were
on pc
but that's often outweighed by how fun
it is to be able to play this game in
all these new places that you could
never play before so let me just say
ergonomically i think the steam deck is
pretty great it's much much bigger than
a switch but it's still impressively
light it's 688 grams basically it's like
one and a half times the switch it's
made of all plastic here but there is
not much flexion at all no creaking the
thing feels very well built and then
there's just
tons of controls so first of all it's a
glass touch screen up front seven inch
diagonal 1280 by 800 60 hertz ips
display
then there's abxy buttons there's a
d-pad there's two thumb sticks with this
nice texture there's also two touch pads
with haptic feedback there's a menu
button top right and a view button top
left the steam button that brings up the
steam menu on the bottom left and the
quick settings button on the bottom
right that gives you things like battery
life and frame rate limits and
brightness etc
then there's four shoulder buttons on
the top r1 r2 and l1 l2
and there's four more assignable grip
buttons around the back so r4 r5 and l4
l5
and they're all pretty well laid out i
mean those back buttons sit comfortably
where your fingers usually sit the grip
is nicely curved it feels natural to
hold the speakers of course are up front
facing you and then up top is the volume
buttons a headphone jack for some
headphones and a usb c port for charging
but then at the bottom is a micro sd
card slot which is surprisingly
important see the 399 is the baseline
version and that will get you 64 gigs
the lowest amount of storage and that
also is the slowest storage
if you haven't just check your steam
library real quick there's a pretty good
chance you'll find at least one game
that's more than 64 gigs so this 256 gig
version i have here is 529 and then
there is a half terabyte 649 version
coming later which apparently also has a
nano etched display but yeah i only have
two games that i'm playing on my steam
library right now one is called dirt
rally it's about 40 gigs and the other
is nba 2k 22
and it's 117 gigs
and so i don't really have much room for
any other games but the nice thing is
like i said there's that micro sd card
slot which just pops in and out like
normal like that and you can just add a
terabyte of extra storage and
impressively and thankfully that
actually will give you totally normal
performance playing games off of that
card so i would recommend
saving a little bit and getting one of
these too but yeah once i got the steam
deck really all i wanted to do was just
play some games so i got my two good
games going and immediately was playing
them in places i had never played those
games before typically i have to sit in
the one room where the gaming pc and
monitor and keyboard and everything is
set up but i was playing dirt rally
sitting on a couch or just in random
other rooms this could easily extend out
anywhere the back of a car or on a
flight the waiting room at a doctor's
office i don't know basically anywhere
where you can catch a spare hour or two
you can play a game now there is a tiny
bit of latency that you can sort of
mentally calibrate for again this goes
back to me saying you're not going to be
as good in the game as you would be on a
pc but i was able to get used to it
enough to make it enjoyable and i think
that's where focusing on the numbers on
paper will get you kind of lost you know
it runs a custom amd apu it has 16 gigs
of ram you might be tempted as a gamer
to say oh well what if what if it had 90
hertz or 120 hertz display or focusing
on faster storage to reduce latency a
little would have been nice but the
battery life
the battery life
it's rated for two to eight hours
and i'll just say you'll definitely get
closer to two a lot more often than
you'll get close to eight so 60 hertz is
fine
1280 by 800 on a 7 inch display is fine
and the controllers and ergonomics are
really good they're comfy the other game
that i mentioned i play a lot nba 2k
works great again you got to take a few
games to calibrate for the slight delay
between moving the controls and then the
actual player moving even if you're not
playing online like it's most noticeable
when shooting free throws or really any
type of shooting where that's timing
related but once you get the hang of
that it's fun i mean i've never i've
literally never played nba 2k anywhere
other than on my couch with the
playstation in front of me or on a
gaming computer in the studio so i'm out
here sitting on a random couch with no
tv in the room playing 2k on a flight
playing 2k anywhere away from the normal
setup is so new it just felt like
unlocking a level of fun that i couldn't
access before but here's the x factor
these games that i've been playing work
really well on the steam deck because
those controls are already mapped great
because those are games that are
typically played with controllers i mean
you could get a wheel for dirt but those
are games that are already mapped great
so you'll notice if you try to go into
the menus in 2k or something with a
different part of the deck like the
touchscreen or the touch pads
yeah those things don't really work very
well they've tried to map it but it's
pretty bad it's inconsistent it's
imprecise you'd never use them but at
least the controls that are supposed to
work do that's why it's in the great on
deck section in the steam store they had
to make a specific section for games
whose controls map over perfectly but
there's a lot of games whose controls
don't map over well or have unknown
compatibility where it's really a
toss-up and there are games in the steam
store that are just straight up
unsupported on steam deck and they won't
work so anytime you search the store you
can leave verified games only which
works really well or you can risk it a
little and include games that are
playable but not perfect and that'll
just be up to you as of right now apex
legends pubg destiny 2 fall guys and a
bunch of others are completely
incompatible with the steam deck so in
that sense it's pretty rough but this
isn't really meant to be looked at like
a switch on steroids this really is much
more of a full-on computer
shrunken down
to be
more portable so the hard carry case
that it comes with i really like it i
think it's very good the fans and the
exhaust vent at the top are pretty much
constantly working it takes like five
minutes of gaming before it's spitting
out hot air and the 45 watt charger that
it comes with
you pretty much have to take it
everywhere if you want a game for more
than about three hours but the reward
for dealing with all of these trade-offs
is being able to play these games in all
sorts of places that you've probably
never been able to play these games
before and that's the fun of it so even
though they're ergonomically similar and
it's like tempting to compare this to a
nintendo switch
they're not even in the same category at
all and they're for completely different
audiences too the steam deck already has
a pretty hardcore community that's
mapping the controls to various new
games this thing has gotten a ton of
software updates from valve since i
first got it bug fixes extra features
experimental stuff there's people out
here plugging it into a monitor and a
keyboard and a mouse and it'll happily
run linux like a straight up portable pc
and apparently if you take it apart
there's enough room inside for a whole
air tag so instead of waiting for a lost
and found feature to be added you can
just do that but probably my favorite as
you can see is my white steam deck
there's of course no actual white steam
deck but i've got a skin on it from our
channel sponsor dbrand and they also
sent over their steam deck glass which
is available now it is a precisely
perfect fit screen protector that keeps
the screen sensitivity on point and
they've got a whole line of steam deck
accessories under the project name kill
switch which is hilarious so the steam
deck is fun even if i'm not the biggest
gamer in the world just being able to
take these couple new games to new
places and play them in places i would
never ordinarily be able to that's the
fun of it if you want that experience
then you should try to get a steam deck
but there's not a lot of people in that
group but if you are
yeah check it out even if half the games
don't work yet
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one
peace
[Music]